- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
Today Paige and I are going to teach you
all about your new best friend, the comma.
It is a piece of punctuation
that has many many functions.
We're just going to broadly
overview them today.
The comma is an extremely
powerful piece of punctuation,
can do a whole bunch of stuff.
So Paige, what is the most pertinent
or important thing that the comma does?
- [Voiceover] I would probably say
that it is separating sentence elements.
- [Voiceover] So that's
like its broad super-power--
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] But lots of
stuff falls under that.
So it's like it has laser
vision but it can not only
use that laser vision to
boil water, but it can also
cut through steel.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] So this is a
superhero punctuation mark.
I'll make that into a C for comma.
So okay, so how is the comma
going to save the day today?
How's it going to make
our sentences make sense?
What are some of the
things that it separates?
- [Voiceover] So it can
separate elements of lists.
- [Voiceover] For lunch I had tofu,
spam,
and seaweed.
A very Hawai'ian lunch.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hm, delicious.
- [Voiceover] So it's separating
these elements of this list.
I guess commas can also separate dates.
- [Voiceover] That's right.
- [Voiceover] So for example,
here in the United States,
National Blueberry
Muffin Day is July 11th,
and if we wanted to refer to a historical
blueberry muffin day,
let's say July 11th, 1981.
- [Voiceover] Wow.
- [Voiceover] It was the
best muffin day ever.
- [Voiceover] I wish I could
have been around for that.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, okay, so
a comma can separate lists
and it can be used for dates,
and we can also set off
things at the beginning of sentences,
like basically, everything is great.
The comma has a bunch
of different functions.
It's this super-useful multi-tool.
It's the superhero of
a piece of punctuation.
So we're not going to cover
all of that in this video.
The most important thing
to remember about the comma
is what it does is
separate sentence elements.
It can separate clauses,
it can separate items
in a list, it can separate dates.
Usually, when you're
trying to make a separation
within a sentence, you use a comma.
So Paige, so what are some
things that commas can't do?
- [Voiceover] That's a great question.
So, commas can't go at
the end of a sentence.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so I couldn't be like,
I want to go swimming comma.
It couldn't end a sentence that way.
- [Voiceover] Right, you need to say
something after the comma.
- [Voiceover] So this is no good.
Or you have to keep going,
like I'm going to go
swimming, and then sailing.
And end it with a period, like that.
That's totally fine usage for a comma.
If it's in the middle of a sentence
but not at the end of a sentence.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
commas only go in the middle.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] So comma separates
stuff which therefore means
it has to be in-between something.
- [Voiceover] Right, there has
to be something to the left
and something to the right.
- [Voiceover] Cool, all right.
That's a comma--
- [Voiceover] Yeah--
- [Voiceover] Wouldn't you say?
- [Voiceover] I think we have
successfully met the comma.
- [Voiceover] Cool,
you can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.